So it's time to look at how we make our AI agents traverse the world as they perform their behaviors.
Unreal comes with a system that supports land-based AI movement straight out of the box, that being the navigation mesh.
As we mentioned in our gameplay talk, Pawn is the base possessable class that the Unreal Engine offers,
but it's also not assumed to be humanoid.
Whereas character is the first derived version of Pawn that makes an assumption of the vertically aligned
humanoid entity, and it's primarily these entities that make use of the navigation system.
The navigation mesh is generated in the editor,
and it queries the environment on generation to understand where AI can traverse and which areas are non-navigable.
It can be both generated ahead of time, but also change at runtime to support dynamic levels.
Navigation modifier volumes can be used to apply navigation costs or blocks.
These make areas of the navigation mesh cheaper or more expensive to traverse.
Physical objects placed in the world can control whether or not they affect this navigation mesh or not.
Different navigation data can be built for different agents.
Say we have an agent that's particularly big or another one that is particularly small.
Their navigation requirements, of course, will be different from each other, and as such we can build different navigation data to represent their needs.
Navigation links can be formed between navigation mesh edges to allow AI to traverse spaces where navigation meshes may not exist,
for instance, jumping from one mesh onto another one.
As we mentioned, the navigation mesh is generated within the editor, though it does not come built in with any level.
In order to generate a navigation mesh, we must drop a navigation mesh bounds volume into the level,
which can be found in the place actors window under volumes.
We can then resize this volume to cover the area that we wish to have a navigation mesh generated for.
In order to know if your navigation mesh has been generated correctly, we can hit the P key in the editor.
If a navigation mesh has been successfully generated for this level, we'll be able to visualize it in the viewport.
In the picture to the right, we can see some of the controls that we have available to us on our navigation mesh once it has been generated.
For example, we can control the max slope angle that this navigation mesh will support.
Another key parameter to control with navigation meshes is whether the runtime generation is static or dynamic.
Static, of course, will be cheaper than its dynamic counterpart,
where it's important to understand what your project needs and that they may vary along the way.
If we've got a completely static scene, then a static generation nav mesh will be perfectly fine.
But if your game has got an ever-changing scene, such as trees falling over or objects being built at runtime,
then a dynamic navigation mesh will be required.
Lastly, it's really important to understand that physical objects in the world individually control whether they affect the nav mesh or not.
So ensuring that these are correctly set up is really important.
In the picture above, we can see a generated navigation mesh.
As well as that, we can also see that the tables and chairs have affected the generation of that mesh,
so that AI can reason that they cannot traverse through the table and chairs, they need to walk around them.
The navigation mesh system in Unreal supports different navigation meshes for different AI agents,
and it's important to understand that the navigation mesh system in Unreal supports different navigation meshes for different AI agents.
As we mentioned earlier, as can be seen in the image on the slide, we can define a humanoid profile that supports AI agents of a certain radius and height.
We can also determine other aspects of the navigation mesh generation.
This allows us to support different agents with appropriate navigation meshes for them to use.
A larger AI agent may not be able to navigate through narrow spaces in the terrain, so therefore our navigation mesh should not allow them to do so.
As we mentioned a few slides back, we can also make use of navigation link proxies and navigation modifiers to affect how our AI can traverse across the environment.
Navigation link proxies, as the name suggests, allow us to link between gaps in the mesh.
An AI agent can utilize these links to temporarily leave the navigation mesh.
In the example above, the AI agent can use a navigation link to jump off the ledge to get to another piece of the mesh.
As well as linking navigation mesh edges together, we can utilize navigation modifiers to affect navigation in several ways.
With navigation modifiers, we can do some of the following.
We can block navigation, and this is fairly self-explanatory.
This will create a void of navigation in the desired area, meaning that the AI will be forced to move around it.
We can also affect the cost of the navigation.
This essentially means that we can outline areas of our nav mesh that are high or low cost.
A high-cost area will be used as a fallback or last resort, whereas a low-cost area will be used as a preferred or priority path.
As an example, we can see in the image above that we can define an area by the wall that is not a desirable path for the AI agent to choose.
However, if we must, it will traverse through that area to its goal location if no other route can be found.
We can leverage this to create immersive experiences for the players, where the AI cleverly chooses other ways of getting to the player that avoid a choke point in the image.
This can be easily married up with the concept of pathing heuristics in the more classical A-Star implementations of pathfinding.